the playstation app has become an
absolute game changer for ps5 users
especially if you like to share your
favorite screenshots and video clips
online or save them straight to your
phone in the past this was a more
cumbersome process as you had to connect
a usb thumb drive or external hard drive
and then transfer over to a computer
while that method does still work thanks
to the playstation app you can now
download recent screenshots or videos
directly to your ios or android device
first you'll need to set up a few things
on your ps5 console start by going to
your settings and then captures and
broadcasts then go to the screenshot
format and make sure it's set to png
rather than jpeg this will ensure your
screenshots are the highest possible
quality if you're playing on an hdr
display you'll also have the option of
whether or not you want the screenshots
to capture hdr however enabling the hdr
capture locks you out of selecting the
png format personally i recommend
turning the hdr capture off and going
with png next you'll want to go back to
the previous menu and scroll all the way
to the bottom make sure auto upload is
enabled this will ensure your
screenshots and video clips from your
ps5 will be uploaded and made available
on the ps app for 14 days after you
create them note the uploads will only
begin once you have this setting enabled
so any screenshots you've already taken
will not show up in the app now we're
ready to grab our mobile device and fire
up the ps app you'll need to tap the
fourth icon along the bottom row here
which is the game library then tap
captures and you'll see a list of all
the photos and videos you've captured on
your ps5 for the past 14 days scroll
down tap on a photo and then tap the
arrow in the bottom right corner to
download straight to your device if
you'd like to download more than one
screenshot at a time tap the white
circle and check mark icon in the bottom
right of the captures page here at the
time of this video recording 4 is the
maximum number you can select at a time
hopefully that gets bumped up in the
future and then finally head to the
photos app on your phone where you'll
find all your new screenshots and videos
you'll even find that a new folder has
been auto-generated for you called ps
app which will house all your downloads
directly from the playstation app as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon